alors ici aussi à des histoires de
drague plutôt insolite concernant les
chroniqueurs ici autour de la table des
anecdotes vont s'afficher sur l'écran
vous allez jouer avec nous également à
chez vous pour essayer de trouver et
vous allez c'est trouver de qui il
s'agit voilà autour de la tap un bien ma
tentative de drague a fini aux urgences
je me suis tapé la vente devant tous mes
amis un ami ma compagne est un rendez
vous merci mme bélanger un abîme
accompagne un rendez vous amoureux il
est reparti avec ma dulcinée
j'ai demandé à ma jumelle de draguer
quelqu'un ma place c'est à dire qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui mesure l oin voilà ici
autour de la table il a essayé de me
faire croire qu'il était un grand
baroudeur
la mère de la fille que je draguais a
essayé de se jeter sur moi où je me suis
fait draguer par un commissaire de
police à votre avis qui a eu une
tentative de drague qui a fini aux
urgences c'est isabelle oury bah oui
c'est ça oui qu'est ce qui s'est passé
c'est pas exactement les urgences on a
dû faire venir les pompiers
assez pour ça parce que les brevets et
gavé je vais 17 ans il y avait un mec
qui me draguer mais je savais qu'il
avait des gros bouts l'arrêt qu'il
fallait le séduire intellectuellement et
c'était un fou de master mind donc il
vient chez moi ils savaient pas quoi
dire moi non plus et je lui dis sur ce
qu'ils aient une partie de mastermind
bio mais oui quelle bonne idée ça
démarre bien
on commence à jouer maskemane est
brusquement je sais pas pourquoi il me
dit un jour je t'offrirai un bijou est
comme ça je te mettrai la zone urbaine
on va faire comme avec l'open mastermind
et je mets le club basque à mains à
l'entrée de la marine je pense au
ridicule que j'ai j'éclate de rire et le
pion de mme ashton
[Musique]
j'essaye de le faire redescendre
délicatement impossible et puis ça
commençait au bout d'une demi heure
j'avais toujours le truc coincé dans les
sinus me faisais semblant ne pas s'en
rendre compte on a dû appeler les
pompiers un jeune pompier beau comme un
dieu
il a dû aller chercher le match normal
avec une mèche
désormais il n'y a pas de le tuer à 6 e
rang pour le mali est ressorti avec tout
ce qui fait tout le matos
[Rires]
mike est belle histoire on était trois
potes et puis on tombe sur un groupe de
quatre filles ouais cette fille est un
pote sort avec une fille de ce groupe là
est le 2ème euros par une fille aussi
dans le groupe de quatre filles je les
trouve vraiment pas mal du tout et il
réussit à la branche est donc
naturellement je me dis le reste de feu
et je vais à la troisième elle a fait a
certainement pas j'étais en première ou
en terminale et je voulais aller au
cinéma avec la fille que je voulais
draguer puis de donner un peu de force
était un peu timide j'y suis allée que
meyer habib et c'est lui qui l'a emballé
au cinéma qui est reparti avec c'est
l'histoire de votre vie ça
[Musique]
je devais porter plainte ce que je
m'étais fait voler un scooter et
j'arrive au commissariat tout se passe
bien le commissaire arrive et je sens
vraiment que je lui tape dans l'oeil
london ça car genre vraiment si vous
avez le moindre problème je suis fumeur
et deux jours après le commissaire
m'appelle en ne convoquant les
infractions donc vous revenir au
commissariat nous avons un gros problème
par rapport aux vols de scooters et tout
j'y vais je ne comprends pas l'intérêt
du rendez vous puisque je passe une
heure dans le bureau le mec me raconte
toute sa vie mais vraiment depuis sa
naissance jusqu'à sa note de l'essence
un peu visiblement torturé
bon je m'en vais je me dis ok sympa
j'ose pas l'envoyer paître parce qu'il
est commissaire le lendemain il me
rappelle et il a eu des revenus on a
trouvé ce côté là il veut dire à l'eau
c'est des commissaires à l'amérique
je reviens encore le surlendemain parce
qu'il m'avait fait croire qu'on avait
retrouvé mon scooter rien du tout et là
le mec concrètement me demande un
rendez-vous galant en place entre quatre
murs avec la secrétaire à côté saint
jacques et je la jeanne envoyer balader
et depuis j'ai beaucoup de
contraventions j'aime bien le gars moi
le gars qu'est ce qui s'est passé alors
j'étais très amoureux j'arrive pour
l'avoir à vélo je retire mes pinceaux
haye et à vélo ce jeu je pense à
l'appartement
c'était en fait autant que les siècles
déjà percé vélo j'étais jeune j'étais
jeune j'avais 18 19 ans donc je frappe
et là j'allais la voir la mer m'ouvre de
ma future conquête j'espérais la mer
m'ouvre et me dira vous dévoile
s'appelle florence vous venez voir
florence elle est sous la douche
non dit engagé à revenir elle dit non
parce que moi j'en sors non elle était
en peignoir et ac n'ont pas nié direct
non et oui directement
c'est tony parker
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mais comme je vous dis que c'est parmi
tout au plus à hasnon mais je le crois
parce que ça cesse a alors est donc très
belle femme et j'étais impressionné les
tempes et mal retire le peignoir me
prend par les l'aller les parties
m'emmène sur le canapé mais oui et là je
vivrai votre finale mondiale est sous la
douche
elle passe énormément de temps sous la
douche bah oué erreur et j'ai passé des
noms et je suis reparti mais vous êtes
vous être opportuniste unis la mer ni la
fille
[Applaudissements]